no surprise this movie is one letter
removed from being just plain old sins
ah credits I mean this is an Knights
first film after sixth sense and then
unbreakable easily his best film despite
your opinion on the matter
so these credits here should have been a
huge red flag force on where his career
was headed these are some ballsy ass
credits here yo people shut the fuck up
and read our credits the music alone
will spook you and draw you into the
film also Hitchcock was a pussy and I'm
is better and that's coming from someone
who generally enjoys this film picture
tells us everything we need to know one
of these parents died and one of these
parents is Mel Gibson so dead mom cliche
already in effect character suddenly
wakes up to jump scare the audience
cliche just show us already ah crop
circles didn't those get debunked as
man-made hoaxes long ago aliens are
dicks to cornfields movie gives us not
only our current location in the story
but also the exact mileage to the
nearest large city even though they have
plenty of chances throughout the movie
to let us know where these characters
are in relation to Philadelphia
here's a jump-scare manufactured for the
audience that involves the sheriff just
waltzing into frightened people's homes
unannounced and just leaning on a door
waiting to surprise anyone who might
happen to wander around the corner
that's gonna burn eh again what a dick
they stop calling me father what's wrong
I don't hear my children obvious double
meaning dialogue is double meaning
double meaning also not hearing your
children is bad not hearing them when
they're actually making noise when the
dog tried to attack her daughter who was
probably screaming during the whole
thing is even worse movie conveniently
skips over the little boys
single-handedly takes down a rabid
German Shepherd scene which is
understandable since it's impossible
god damn it does this kid have asthma or
were you yeah exactly
it's like the dog attack took place in a
silent film or something no growling
barking or screaming dog forensics ah
repetition on the water next year bit
old character talking about water
inadvertently voices the audience's
concerns with the script of this movie
I admit that's pretty scary but what the
hell is he doing on the roof for
Christ's sakes back on his plane at the
roof is a great hiding place I guess
thankfully tonight Merrill fell asleep
inside the main house instead of his
upstairs barn apartment so that he could
help out in this alien hunt huh because
now we know for sure he can cast away
better than that signs that you're not
going to see too many aliens in this
picture now what's wrong with this one
ha ha kids a weird stupid and annoying
also plot how was work at the gas
station this one line of dialogue is an
orgy of evidence that the screenwriter
wanted us to know Merrill a former
baseball prodigy he has a should be job
I never got a chance to tell you but I
thought you're moving in here with your
brother after movie finds a hand fisted
way to finally tell us how Graham and
Merrill are related
Ludi wants you to know these water
glasses are important sorry ok so far I
have it was very dark remember how this
scene started
you got a no baby monitor around and
then Graham went to tell beau to turn
the tv down how did talking about
intruders get into talking about
walkie-talkies over 6-feet it was very
dark
the fuck it was very light remember when
the lights outside went on mysteriously
just before you ran outside the scenes
comical but you're not having any way of
describing the obviously around 6-foot
being on top of your roof is actually
maddening this guy got on our roof in
like a second our roof is 10 feet high
they have women's high jumping in the
Olympics okay so we're looking for an
Olympic high jumper who hangs out around
Pennsylvania farms honestly why haven't
you already solve this case did anyone
listen to this dialogue being skeptical
is a good thing a great thing but how
silly is that also high jumping record
for a man is a little over 7 feet and
for a woman it's a little over 6 so not
only an Olympic high jumper but the Good
Will Hunting of high jumpers I know
you're making a point here I just don't
know what it is good point and that
point is we don't know anything about
the person you saw bullshit you know
it's roughly six feet tall move silently
he was on the freaking roof and jump
from there to basically the cornfield 50
yards away whew oversimplifying calm I
don't know baby wanted to check in the
sofa cushions child asks parent where
the remote is before checking the sofa
cushions child fails at being a child
excluding the possibility that a female
scandinavian olympian was running around
outside our house last night
what else might be a possibility finally
someone realizes how ridiculous that
sounded the local cops should have kept
the Olympic high jumping to herself
and looked into it after debunking
aliens anyone who might have a grudge do
something against you might not have
liked the fact that you left the church
man this movie thinks it's still fucking
clever about slipping exposition into
the dialogue okay I was out of line with
the whole female Scandinavian Olympian
thing don't really every station oh come
on crop circles that's the story that's
so big that it's on every station as
aliens are landing mainly in India and
some random farm in Pennsylvania also
two places that just happen to have
significance for the director of this
movie also why isn't the media Oliver
Graham's farmhouse right now with us
being such a huge story also no one who
watches the skies for a living so at
least 18 ships come down to India
there's like over a billion people there
what in God's name is going on I don't
know I'll check the 1984 East German
Olympic high jumping team you check the
members of Led Zeppelin two or three
guys can make a design the size of the
one in your field over night isn't it
boards and ropes I think the same thing
when I want to Improv Everywhere videos
take them into town and get their minds
in your mind on everyday things like
your wife's killer send out a
reconnaissance group very small check
things out this crazy military asshole
is right but why land in large fields of
crops don't they know that she remember
of these things alert people to the
presence maril is for any reason
considering joining the military it's
still the record right god the bat at
home in my brothers living room even
though I live in the upstairs part
apartment but whatever plot and stuff
why why aren't you in the pros making
stacks of cash and getting your toes
licked by beautiful women he has the
minor-league strikeout record the guy
hit a lot of Homer's but he struck out a
lot yep they don't allow those dickheads
and the majors miles like class a screw
up dude you are a late 20-something
wearing a leather jacket filling out
recruitment paperwork at the army office
in bumfuck Pennsylvania mayoral maybe
the kettle but you're the fucking pot
and you know it
phony confession on the part of both
parties you said him Morgan plays the
pronoun game with the audience so that
we have to figure out who the hell hem
means also yes Morgan that's the guy who
will fall asleep at the wheel during
Avatar The Last Airbender
he's the reason you can fit the whole
family in the doorframe shot hunt it's a
code
who are you kill be foster these aliens
really that good at not being seen or is
this a found footage movie they were not
detected by radar by either country but
their communication between each other
can be picked up by baby monitors you
can't have it both ways man everything
people have written about in science
books is going to change overly eloquent
kid is overly eloquent also I have a
feeling that Morgan picked up this one
VHS tape so we could have this speech
about how important the discovery of
alien life is find another tape I mean
right I was about to say they only have
one freaking tape in this house and it
turns out Morgan was being addictive
bows ballet recital
oh come on I'm using your tape you're
seeing a live feed live news broadcast
about alien spaceships somehow had no
newscaster talking for the last 45
seconds while the family argued about
which videotape to use everything they
wrote in science books is about to
change
if you have a VHS tape with a ballet
recital on it go ahead and tape over
that hey you in the audience don't
forget about all these water glasses
okay you the kindnesses signed roll
credits there is no one watching out for
us Meryl we are all on our own
asshole former priests who legitimately
seemed to want to help comfort his
brother a second ago who doesn't
about-face and crushes Merrill's comfort
like a bug previously before science
just be playing free free rabbit or Tea
Party or something
loving uncle suggests his brothers kids
dabble in furry play doctor crop circles
I think you'd be some kind of landmark
visual mapping system so they could
navigate and place 18 of them inside
India
how many landmarks did these aliens need
it really really doesn't actually it
makes the opposite of sense why couldn't
they coordinate from space before we're
entering our atmosphere or back before
leaving their home planet how can they
be so advanced enough to have cloaking
technology but primitive enough to have
to carve from the planet's surface to
remember where they're supposed to be
going 80 dolls airplane wallpaper
revolutionary soldier lamp next to a
stuffed horse this room is an orgy of
evidence that in a massive house Graham
still forces his son and daughter to
share one tiny bedroom like our house no
it's called screenwriting happens every
day kid
you knew that was a mapper he said one
word director who thinks he's hit Scott
is Hitchcockian in all the wrong ways
also this might be the most convenient
alien visit you could possibly dream up
these elusive aliens disappear when the
light hits your retinas but this one got
caught in Ray Reddy's house rummaging
through the pain tree the one guy who
happens to have a major history with
this movie's main character when I knew
it was inside the house think of any
other number to call it panic how did
you not crack up laughing while
delivering this dialogue you wrote it
you're directing it and you're saying it
nine-one-one exists you know people know
about it too I promise no one is dialing
seven digits after an alien breaks into
their home no matter how guilt-ridden
their conscience is 10-15 seconds when I
pastor walking later we find out she
liked to take walks before dinner but
almost Graham's wife doing walking
around on a dark lonely road also I call
bull on the idea that she was walking
before dinner since this guy said he was
working really long hours that night and
there was no one on the road signifying
midnight or later it had to be at that
right moment at 10 15 seconds when I
passed her walking was like it was meant
to be what an asshole people who kill
reverend's wives aren't exactly I
should've the fun in line in heaven dude
there are way bigger issues keeping you
out of heaven the biggest God is an
avatar the last airbender fan or he was
at least none of them are really near
water I don't think they like water also
I think murals baseball bat might come
in handy I have no basis for this but
remember that also Jesus Christ
you can't resist casting yourself in
your movie okay fine I sort of get that
but to give yourself the key
foreshadowing dialogue peace which
ultimately foreshadows with the subtlety
of my dick you dude why don't you just
make a movie called I'm awesome and call
it a day
don't open my pantry father I found one
of them in there and locked him in
something how also as soon as I lock
them in the pantry I panicked and called
you father not the authorities and then
sat in my truck hoping you'd show up
after that weird phone call where I
didn't say my name or anything move
children
vamanos that's racist
Spanish children speak mostly Spanish
until they need to say keywords so
English speakers can understand also
this movie really did become
found-footage for a second alien in the
cupboard also I guess it can't be a
proper barricade unless you stick one
measly chair on top of the main thing
that's barricading the door like chair
does nothing people nothing
character without any motivation beyond
raw curiosity to science to
unnecessarily confront what he clearly
has enough evidence to know is an alien
birds fly away to signify something
scary happen cliche we get it you love
Hitchcock enough already I heard a
theory that they don't like places near
water yeah you've heard it from the
director / screenwriter geez this movie
Telegraph's its punches like one of
Robert Downey junior Sherlock Holmes
boxing opponents challenge me up right
unlike everything you've been saying I
saw one of them are here Eddie's house
much like hey I'm calling the cops felt
stupid to me so I just left up there
with a three fingered hand in his pantry
my vote counts is to Bush you're
cheating come on the guy was a priest
and just recently started losing his
faith in the past six months
his kids aren't swearing at him yet with
any kind of confidence and where you've
also lived without her - I'm just saying
I change see this is why you shouldn't
let women vote oh wait I changed my vote
you can't change your vote raise your
hand
mutiny also why the hell did you suggest
a second option and hold a vote in the
first place if you were planning to
force the lake as the solution why do
this this is what happens when people
treat parenting like democracy because
as the movie will go on to prove you
would have been much safer at the lake
follow your instincts man because they
seem to have trouble with pantry doors
but seriously there's no reason I should
tell anyone about the alien locked up in
the pantry did this guy who's his faith
and common sense a mom joins Nairobi
Beijing and Jerusalem as the latest to
confirm the appearance of lights
hey not everything has to be about
America but damn this family lives in
Pennsylvania and we still haven't heard
about New York Chicago Houston Los
Angeles or Cody Wyoming yet
errant lights and over 274 cities just
think it'll be 400 within the hour and
not one country has started firing
missiles at them yet get out of here
with his fantasy bullet
peering at her within one mile of crop
signs Horan application made imagine
what the crop circles are a map how how
are they a map if they are these aliens
are stupid teacher states immediately
appreciating an attack maneuver sure
taking their sweet-ass time though
aren't they
Earth's weather patterns somehow no
aliens are about to attack hey you you
and everyone in Hollywood kid except
Jodie Foster and Robert Downey jr. no
one can stop us from enjoying this meal
so enjoy it
I really cry supper Tapani you don't
mean the happening do you these aliens
are here to attack but apparently don't
know anything about setting a fire or
trying to smoke out a family that
barricaded themselves this advanced
alien race only knows sheer force how
the hell did he find that in total
darkness acts just happens to have the
perfect floor to door knob height to
which the doorknob perfectly why didn't
Graham know immediately where this cool
chute was it's a pretty damn obvious
unique place in the basement that would
be impossible to forget also did this
asshole wander through the basement in
the dark all the way next to the coal
chute it was pitch-black in the area he
decided to walk what the hell aliens
don't want to kill humans they're just
starting their own prank channel on
YouTube apparently flashlights
ironically doesn't allow me to see
things well I sure am glad Morgan came
out of that okay I think but I don't
know movie about people refuses to
update us on the status of other people
after harrowing experience we don't have
his medicine cliche asthma kid doesn't
have his medicine cliche they didn't
come here for a planet this is a raid
they came here for us
lucky is how they're leaving why did
they make such a huge production out of
this this should have been an easy
so-called raid but they sat around for
weeks doing nothing waiting until this
family here boarded up their windows
because hey they can't see us well in
the dark we might be more powerful than
them but get invisibility raids only
sleeping fires or so twelve eight hours
how did they manage that people must
have figured out a way to beat them
allergic to earth I'm gonna go with
allergic to earth everyone has a
weakness right which for some reason
hasn't been broadcast on this radio I'm
listening to for however long it took me
to get all the other information I just
relate to you in the middle you mean the
Middle East actually solved a problem
with war this time three small cities
there found a primitive method to defeat
them we have no further details at this
time what what impossible is what that
is how can you know about the defeating
and it's methods primitiveness without
knowing any further details you
conveniently lack
important details just so we can have
this finale newscast alien has what it
needs and could have left before anyone
knew but decided to needed to stay in
the living room and get its ass kicked
let this be a lesson to you kids if the
guy who fell asleep driving and crushed
your wife with this truck happens to
call you one day and tells you as an
alien in the pantry you need to call an
authority figure who can do something
about it just in case you didn't
remember that scene where Graham chomped
and Aliens fingers off here's a reminder
look I don't care if this chick didn't
scream during her birth I'm pretty sure
she'd be crying and screaming her lungs
out right now I honestly don't know what
any of these assholes human or alien are
doing right now
Swango and marrow wife's last words are
made to fit the narrative but honestly
did he need to remember his dead wife to
understand that there's a baseball bat
hanging on the wall finally finally the
aliens have the same weaknesses the
aliens and signs also why the would
these aliens attack a planet that is 71%
deadly to them and sure is a good thing
that the owner has this weird
fascination with water dam think about
that kind of craziness they needed the
mom to die so that the brother would
come to live with him use his bat and
accidentally knock over water to kill
the aliens all based on the mom's last
words add to that the alien in the
pantry Graham never reports this is the
most convenient set of plot points since
the three stories that began Magnolia
coasts pretty nifty as asthma actually
helped him here but I'm still wondering
why the alien took four hours to try and
use the poison in the first place or why
he didn't try to use a poison on the
whole family while they stood in the
living room doing nothing oh good for
him it only took fifteen miracles for
him to believe in God again he's a true
patron of faith
don't open my pantry father
[Music]
football practice what's the matter
there's a monster outside my room you
can have a classroom lager and we should
just keep all possibilities available if
you eliminate the impossible whatever
remains however improbable must be the
truth and your wife known like a whole
when they ravaged her again and again
again and again
[Music]
[Applause]
and what kind of machine can bend to
stock a corn over without breaking it
what about a magnet what magnet what
about it
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna have a cheeseburger with bacon
Royale which affiliated stations with
them Orson Welles and the Mercury
Theatre on the air in the war of the
world by 80 well from the moment the
invaders arrived breathe our air ate and
drank they were doomed